why should a brilliant turn out there
are hundreds and hundreds of people
there I'm going to take a guess that
over half of them were liberal democrats
and probably home behalf of them were
newly made up new members of the Liberal
Democrats and is massively encouraging
and I think what we've seen is last
three weeks she's this realization that
via the Liberal Democrat absence from a
government alongside conservatives you
see what we brought to the table wine
liberalism is absolutely essential and
it's tough right the potential abolition
of the human right side so to do with
internet snooping the extremism orders
which are a complete attack on civil
liberties and indeed community diversity
in description and then also things like
the attack on affordable housing the the
right to buy they Housing Association
sell off all those things give a real
sense of why liberalism absolutely
matters it doesn't need to justify it
needs to thrive and so this is an
opportunity to get together literally on
the streets to protest join with other
groups different political organizations
and groups are amnesty as well and the
50-50 campaign all working together to
try and defend our human right there is
nothing esoteric about the Human Rights
Act is about protecting your right my
eyes every community up and down the
country Tip O'Neill the great Democrat
politician once said that all politics
is float
all politics is local and the Human
Rights Act is local it affects you in
your town in your street in your tower
block in your village then it's local I
we do with the people leading the fight
for human rights in this country in your
bid to become Liberal Democrat little
leader you've said that you'd like to
the parr to go back to more of a
campaigning style is this is sort of
thing you mean less traditional
parliamentary party maybe more about
causes but in many ways you might say
the smaller we are in Fault in
Parliament the bigger the issues we need
to campaign on must be and the more
ambitious we must be in terms of how we
go forward with those that campaigning
so here's where example for Human Rights
Act you something which flattens the
liberal civil liberties of every single
person in the country well let's make
sure we find that by a grassroots
campaign we've got all these new members
itching to get involved here's a
campaign they can get involved with and
if you realize that by winning council
elections you can build the level of
support in the country for the Liberal
Democrats for the liberal movement that
challenges things like the human rights
and the challenges things like the
sell-off of our housing association
winning elections is not just thing we
do for sake of it not just because it's
fun we do it it is all of those things
it is 30 it's fun we do it because it
changes lives if you can win even
account of I election it ships the dial
to that one degree that could help to
break the resolve of this tiny Tory
majority and make sure he defend things
like the human right side absolutely the
Liberal Democrats survival I think
thriving as a political movement he's
all about getting out there and building
a movement for the 21st century not the
kind of Edwardian model that all of our
particular parties at the comments do
you think it's fair to say that you're
giving up on parliamentary ambitions
then they know we have absolutely huge
biology ambition but we're not going to
do though is play a silly sterile gaming
Westminster which will trappers and mute
and unmute us all we got to do is get
out there campaign work alongside of
course our members the house of laws
we've got a full set of spokespeople a
gender balanced ethnically balanced team
of spokes legal across Parliament
but one can understand is in the house a
conference we got to use our our weight
but punch above it we're not going
bothering shadowing every single
ministerial statement we're going to
pick issues like housing like human
rights like climate change to get out
there and make a difference campaign in
depth in Parliament on issues that
resonate out there the Tories didn't
mention the British bill of light in the
Queen speech so it's very light to
happen within the next year of apology
coming so why are you spending all this
energy now campaigning against it well
it's brilliantly I think the campaign
that we've been running on human right
his last few weeks has helped test the
Tories nerve and perhaps they have
bottled it we don't know that we have
tape as they bottled it by not
mentioning the abolition of the Human
Rights Act any detail way in the Queen's
Speech of course what was in the Queen's
Speech was the likely introduction of a
data surveillance which is an even
greater sin threat to our civil
liberties and in
the complete divisive and
counterproductive raising of
anti-extremism orders all these things
or practice of liberties a threat to
community cohesion as well so human
writer absolutely on the table whether
their challenge is act or not and its
rightful together today to say the
Liberal Democrats will be at the
forefront of fighting these freedoms I
think all we're getting begin to
understand is across united kingdom on
me there are millions of people who
count themselves as liberals what we're
now seeing is that they need to and they
realize they need to put their money
where their mouths are step up to the
plate and not be just liberals the
Liberal Democrats